he paid 25k for the team it's now worth
something between two and three billion
[Music]
so today's episode is going to make me
incredibly uncomfortable because I know
nothing about sports I was just informed
yesterday when Sean texted me he said
last night last night he goes let's do a
special on the Super Bowl and it's this
Sunday and so that's when I found out
that the Super Bowl was this Sunday I
know nothing at this point and how did
you find out did I text you this yeah
what do you mean you texted me and you
said no I sent you a voice note
I hate voice notes I'm not a fan of
voice notes but you sent me that and
that's when I learned it was the Super
Bowl
um I know nothing about this look I know
what you're thinking you're like look
you're this Macho Man you look like
you're a descendant of Dennis the Menace
you're the you're nobody says Macho Man
since literally the Macho Man was a
character in the 80s I know what you're
thinking you're this All-American hunk
you love sports
and you're partially right I am American
hunk but I know nothing about sports I
don't pay attention to it all here's the
problem in high school sam looked like a
nerd and hung out with a nerd and
developed nerd Hobbies but then Sam now
looks like a jock I CKY but he still has
the nerd Hobbies so you're the high
school quarterback you're the varsity QB
but you still like you know go under the
bleachers and you know like smoke weed
or whatever I don't know what what what
what your like crew was doing
um but but yeah you you fake you fake
like sports I look like Napoleon
Dynamite in high school there's no way
that I was like I knew anything about
sports I don't know anything about about
sports so I'm gonna be what little clubs
were you in
um there was a history a history club
that I that I took part in you and Ben
Wilson yeah I participated in the sport
track and field where I ended up getting
a scholarship for for college and uh
cross country I was a cross-country
track and field guy I'm sorry I'm sorry
I played the best sports
a sport requires like a ball and you
played you know you played things that
just require moving a little faster than
normal
a slight increase in Pace I have said
that I think exercise you should work
out so you can either kill and eat
everyone in the room or be able to
outrun them therefore I only watch UFC
boxing and running I'm just trying to
I'm just trying to kill and eat and run
away that's all I'm trying to do I'm not
trying to like play with the freaking
ball yeah you got fighter fight or
flight uh as your hobby but anyways
either way we're doing the Super Bowl
episode and we're gonna do a little
different so if you listen to this
episode here's my prediction you listen
to this episode
I guarantee you I promise you at least
three
kind of like smart alec know-it-all
comments when you're watching the Super
Bowl with your family and friends on
Sunday because we're just gonna give you
a couple little tidbits that you're
going to be able to say did you know or
you know actually and
um everybody will hate you but they'll
have to admit that you knew some good
[__] so that's what you're gonna get out
of this episode it's all the stuff
around the Super Bowl
um and that's where we're gonna start so
Sam I know this was tough for you to do
research what were you able to pull out
did you have to First Look up the rules
of the game or what I I kind of know the
rules four downs six points and Three
Points uh like when you called me you
said Super Ball and I was like that's
called the Super Bowl no you said the
Super Bowl was this Sunday and I think I
asked if the Lakers were in it
um
no I I researched the more interesting
things which is the rich people who own
the team that's the [__] dude the best
part about sports is watching basketball
and trying to guess who the rich people
are in the front row and Googling them
and reading their Wikipedia that's the
best part that's basically what I did
yeah one of these people does not belong
it's like oh here's a celebrity in the
front row here's Jay-Z
um oh this is 90 year old guy with a 30
year old wife oh let me take a wild
guess at who this individual is and how
they belong here that's significantly
more interesting so let's start with the
owners because I think that is the uh
the interesting place to place to start
so the the two so I went through I did
this thing I was kind of like a little
over the top but I went through it I
created a spreadsheet
um it's not done yet but I'm gonna have
it done by the end of today because I
just got like really into it last night
uh of every owner of in the NFL and I
basically have all these columns like
did they inherit it are they self-made
how much did they buy the team for
what's it worth now what does that mean
in terms of its annual appreciation for
how long they've held it and there's a
couple you know that was a pretty
interesting process the two teams that
are in this right they both of them were
kind of like inherited wealth not
self-made but the Chiefs owner's story
is very interesting did you just check
that one out oh I could tell you all
about it I've known about them so
basically the uh the Philly guy not
interesting
um yeah I mean basically the guy's
Grandpa started a movie theater uh it
expanded they bought other things and
it's just like a nice story but not like
particularly that interesting and now he
was like uh the the guy who owns it now
he was like a professional professor of
social a social policy somewhere and
then was like and I'd like to be rich
I'm going to join the family business
and join the family business and like
you know I guess the most interesting
thing was took out a loan against the
company's assets to buy the Eagles for
185 billion dollars and it turned out to
be a great great buy great great you
know bet that he took so you know
propsed him for that but this Chief
story is kind of like uh like something
from the wild west or like some so it is
this is pretty that's exactly what it's
from and this guy's really fascinating
so the basically the grandson owns it
but it all starts with the grandpa so in
the early 1900s who gets the Billy of
the week is it it's the grandpa right
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the grandpa yeah the guy who runs it now
he's fine he just seems like a square
he's just like a straight edge straight
edge like nice CEO type but the the the
the the the the the the
founder the grandpa he's got the the
perfect name so have you heard is it
called The Wildcatter is that a band or
a Wildcatter yeah
that's that's a great name for what they
used to do so basically in the early
1900s
um his name's H.L hunt that was his name
and if you Google him he looks like a
crazy person so he almost looks like a
the serial killer version of the
Kentucky Fried Chicken Guy like he wears
like a bow tie
he's got like Colonel Sanders was on
season four of you yeah if Colonel
Sanders liked to drink uh Jack Daniels
that's what this guy looks like he's got
like piercing blue eyes and he's got
like a like a shitty eating grin and
he's a wild guy but basically he started
uh he was born in the early 1900s and he
was like a a high school dropout I don't
even think he graduated elementary
school but he was this kind of math
genius type and he was yeah Math Prodigy
and he was a gambler and basically he
ran for ran away from home at the age of
15 uh drifted across the country doing
odds and then like odd jobs eventually
he had like 50 or 100 he gambles it
playing poker turns it into a hundred
thousand dollars which is something like
three million dollars takes that money
and he starts buying oil leases so
um it's kind of almost challenging to
understand today but in the early 1900s
right when my cars were getting popular
America was basically like the Middle
East where we were finding all this cool
uh all this oil here and so people were
like buying plots of land in Ohio PA
Texas in order to find oil well that's
what this guy was doing he was trading
oil leases and he was mildly successful
but at the age of 36 he was like man
this Oil Business sucks because I make a
little money I risk it all sometimes I
lose sometimes I win it's like I'm still
gambling I want to out and so he sells
all of his stuff and he goes fine I'll
do one last thing with the with the
money he has from selling his stuff he
buys this plot of land in Texas and it
turns out to be a lotto ticket where
it's the largest oil Reserve ever
discovered it's in Texas and 20 years
later he becomes the richest man in the
world but
throughout all of this this guy's a
crazy person he ends up having 15 kids
with three different women some of them
were totally degenerates the kids some
of them like like up three or four of
them died from like drugs a plane crash
their crashed motorcycles crash cards
they're just like these crazy kids but a
few of them were awesome so one of his
daughters started the Rosewood hotels
have you heard of that yeah yeah that's
famous yeah it's like a big thing
another one uh Lamar which I think is
the dad of the current CEO of the Chiefs
uh he's like credited as uh naming the
Super Bowl so like he was like pretty
important in sports but this guy's crazy
a few examples
he was like he ends up being the richest
man in the in America but he uh
it was like the bad news here is he was
like a crazy racist and he believed in
like yeah he's like really racist and
you put note here yeah there's a big
footnote here so basically he would like
there was a do you know how like um do
you know how like amongst the black
community in like the 50s and 60s like
getting into Islam was like popular and
they would wear like Muhammad Ali yeah
yeah and that was all because of uh
what's the guy's name Elijah Muhammad he
like started this like um thing in
America I don't know everything what it
stood for but part of the thing was we
need to take black Americans back to
Africa to our homeland first of all
shout out to history Club in high school
look at this look at you it was reeling
and wheeling and dealing with history
right now keep going I know all about
this I know a little bit about this
because Elijah Muhammad was uh homies
with Malcolm X and I I've read a lot
about Malcolm X so anyway
um part of like Elijah Muhammad's deal
his shtick was like we want to separate
the races and this H.L hunt this
southern white guy was like Hey so do I
that's awesome I also want to do that
and so you know Elijah Muhammad was like
you know we want to go back to Africa
and have our own thing H.L hunt was like
great I would like that so he funds that
so you know he's definitely a little
racist a lot racist he also is accused
of being one of the conspiracy
conspirators behind the killing of JFK
this lady like at like a deathbed
confession tells a story she's like I
was in the room with Lyndon B Johnson an
HL hunt where they said this bastard JFK
after tomorrow he's no longer going to
be on our back he's not going to
embarrass anymore we're going to take
care of this of course it was it's kind
of nonsense but this guy had his hands
and everything and he was this if you
Google him
he looks crazy not crazy in a bad way
but like a wild man he looks like a
degenerate a little bit and I don't know
about you Sean do you know any of these
like Southern Texas
uh like entrepreneur types they they no
not personally
so I know a few of them I know this
group of know this group of guys and
they call themselves Capital men
and they're just like they make a little
that sounds powerful it's awesome right
they're just like that sounds a little
awesome yeah I'm gonna steal it I'm a
captain
ourselves we're just a couple of couple
of capital men yeah what do you do I'm a
capital guy basically like there's this
whole like industry of these guys that
have like the southern swoop and like
that haircut and they got a little like
wild in their eyes but they like are
into like hedge funds and into like you
know because a lot of them it's rooted
in like buying and selling oil and being
these like rough and tumble oil guys and
then once you get big enough then it
kind of like comes into like buying
Futures and options to oil and then it's
like oh let's do all this other stuff
with money and start a hedge fund so
there's this like it's like rooted in
that but some of these Southern Rich
entrepreneurs they have this like the
thing about Silicon Valley Tech people
is although they're smart and Rich they
don't know how to spend their money and
they don't know how to have fun and
these usually my Southern friends that
are like rich is successful they don't
have that problem
rich people at silica Valley call
themselves Venture capitalists come on
Capital men
like God damn that that could mean
anything that could mean I I could see
that meaning politics I could see that
meaning money I could see that meaning
like we got we're the guys who got the
money above the people who got money and
it's like you know like we're the real
Capital the capital guys it could also
just be we're real men with a capital M
I'm like I this could go in any
direction and I am I am kind of
interested in all of them this is
fantastic and so so this guy's name HL
hunt
people who do that like initial initial
cool last name like what's the name of
that guy who did the that Big Heist and
like jumped out of a plane DB Cooper
baby yeah DB Cooper Rachel hunt like you
threw a name like that at me like like
God
yeah like God damn I just need one of
these names
LL Cool Jay yeah
hello Cool J man that was one of the old
timers so to summarize this guy he's a
wild man he there's two quotes that he's
kind of credited with saying that like
you and I have probably heard of the
first is uh if you know how rich you are
you aren't very rich I don't know if you
ever heard anyone say that but that's
like one of the things you ain't Rich
yeah and that's and the second thing he
said is money's just a way of keeping
score so those are like two phrases that
dude he also coined the term Super Bowl
his son did yeah so it's like they're
they also came up with the name and The
Branding around the Super Bowl so that's
pretty amazing he paid 25k for the team
it's now worth something between two and
three billion which is uh fantastic
investment you know it did phenomenally
well you know one thing that's really
interesting both these guys uh so both
these guys so he paid 25k it's now worth
two let's say two and a half billion
um the Eagles guy bought it for 185
million now worth also about let's say
two and a half three billion
um that sounds like this incredible
return and it is for sure but put that
into 10 a year what's that 10 a year so
these teams average these seems that
like you know you hear these crazy
stories oh he bought the team for 200
Grand and now it's worth three billion
dollars I said yeah but he did it 42
years ago or whatever and so the math on
oh when I was calculating these for most
of the teams it's just 15 to 20 annual
appreciation compounding and it's like
wow this is uh this is this is like you
know Sam's way of life is just like
right you give me 15 pounding you give
me 15 a year I'm gonna get weak at the
knees 15
that's your same word dude yeah just
whisper in my ear 20 compounding and I
found it was gonna collapse
yeah that's uh that and it's just really
remarkable to just see it kind of play
out that way it's like because it's not
this incredible hockey stick yeah like
another Spike uh in value it's just a if
you annualize it 15 to 20 a year for a
long time and it shows you how Warren
Buffett's so rich the guy's just been
compounding 20 for like 60 years and uh
that's how you get whatever 90 billion
dollars something insane like that what
year did they buy it
um they bought it because I imagine
there's a world where like back you know
whatever year they bought it it was kind
of like buying a soccer team now where
it's like I don't know man it's like
kind of got some traction but I don't
know if this is gonna be part of like
the the fabric of of society
yeah yeah yeah you know like Dana White
behind the UFC in 20 years we're like so
we're just gonna get a bunch of big dumb
gorillas in a cage and make them fight
to the death and like it's gonna be a
legit a legitimate sport you know what I
mean yeah yeah so these guys are rich
though they're worth like 15 billion
dollars now so they're they're a very
rich family
um okay so let's do some other things
now let's Zoom all the way in I got a
little niche business that's kind of
interesting so when I was thinking about
football or think about the Super Bowl
from like uh a business point of view
you kind of it's a different lens you
take a look at it from a different angle
one of the things I noticed when I was
watching the playoffs this year I was
like
dude all these things that I just take
for granted because there's just a
regular part of the game
I'm like they didn't just happen that
way somebody decided we're gonna do this
right we're gonna sing the national
anthem before every game and everybody's
gonna stand up and they're gonna take
off their hats with their hand on their
hearts and we're gonna do this and then
the Jets Are Gonna Fly Over the game and
it's like why are these airplanes flying
over the stadium I don't know if you've
seen this like they do the flyover and
it's like again these aren't just they
didn't just happen to happen somebody
somewhere in some room was like we're
gonna do it this way and these things
cost money to do and they take time to
do
so I'm like What's the strategy here and
I read this article and it kind of said
it well it goes the NFL has draped
itself in the flag and
um and it's so true basically like that
from a branding point of view the NFL
basically when you watch a game the Pomp
and Circumstance makes you feel like
this is a patriotic
event we are all proud to be an American
like that's like the like they they
should just play that song at the
beginning of the games in fact and so I
was like where did each of these come
from and so I started looking into it a
couple crazy things one the military
basically pays the NFL tens of millions
of dollars per year to do this stuff
because it's basically a giant
recruiting event for the military so
they they
the flyover they have to do these
anyways as like part of their training
missions so they're like yeah it does
cost you know uh between like you know
80k to 400k to do these flyovers but we
have to do these as part of routine
training anyways so why not do our
training over the game so we get this
visibility and we get this sort of like
badass thing because if millions of
people are gonna watch these games like
the Super Bowl's watch by 100 million
people
um that's super positive branding it's a
it's it's like co-benefits like what is
that like parasitic relationship where
it benefits both it's like the NFL gets
this association with like true bravery
courage patriotism America and the
military gets like visibility with this
like and because everybody sat down and
watching and it's like a free commercial
for them and so then I was like okay
that's those are interesting what else
it's kind of like it's kind of like when
a white girl posts a picture on Twitter
of her Pitbull and it's like who rescued
who
[Laughter]
special for me today that is amazing
that is the funniest thing you said in a
long time
wow I'm gonna ask you questions about
that joke later because I'm so impressed
by that joke
dude that was great nice tattoo by the
way you want to show this hat I don't
know if you could Flash the tat on your
leg Sam sends this Sam sends a text
message and we will post this on the uh
on the YouTube of the reveal so it's
basically it's like uh like a napkin
covering that whatever the tattoo is you
can see there's a tattoo underneath if
you don't know what it is and it's like
wiping it and then it reveals Sam's
dog's face a huge pit bulls facing out
takes up his entire right leg and um
and as that reveal was happening I was
like I am prepared for this to be
anything like this tattoo you could have
convinced me it was 15 different things
and I would have been like yep I guess
that makes sense I guess that's what the
decision was today like uh oh yeah it's
a map of my favorite you know my
favorite motorcycle Trail through the
Midwest all right sure all right like uh
this is my favorite brand of beef jerky
cool no that's thigh yeah it's a
portrait of Macho Man Randy Savage yep
got it
it's a slim jim like uh I just did I got
the slim jim logo flowers but they're
all just Slim Jims instead of flowers
like all right artistic nice one
um yeah dude so do you know um the best
part about the whole America thing in um
the Super Bowl my favorite one of my
favorite videos and I'm I'm the type of
guy I cried during the Star-Spangled
Banner if it's a good one during this
time it gets me worked up and there's
this one I don't see how I kind of feel
that too I I get worked up or at the
metal ceremonies at the Olympics I
always cry I always get worked up right
um the 1991 version of The Star-Spangled
Banger Banner with Whitney Houston
it's like one of the best videos of all
time have you seen that yes I've gone
down these compilations Marvin Gaye at
the NBA also
won the Whitney Houston one's the best
and it's so impactful that the Library
of Congress they have this like
compilation of like the 50 um greatest
moments in American history and that
Super Bowl thing that her performance
made the list which is like a really big
deal so this whole this partnership
they've done a really good job of making
it a thing and so now the NFL that's a
beautiful line they've draped themselves
in the American flag and by the way if
you're like a band that's struggling to
make it here's your hard pivot here's
your sellout pivot just specialize in
the Star-Spangled Banner and go perform
an epic version of The Star-Spangled
Banner and every college football game
basketball game just go be like the best
Wedding Singer the cover artist of the
national anthem and just specialize in
that have like the most badass
performance of that because I think you
know that's that's one way to not be a
strong you know starving artist okay so
here's uh here's another crazy thing
you've seen at the beginning of the
games they're gonna have this giant flag
on Sunday and the flag is literally the
size of the football field it is a
massive massive flag
again somebody makes that so your boy
goes through and says who the hell makes
this flag sure enough there's like one
lady in Utah
who is the like one of the biggest
providers for this thing it's called 50
star Productions lady in Utah and she
has one employee who hand sews this
thing and he literally goes yeah I just
do it in my basement I don't even come
into the office so there's just a giant
out dude if you leave these things if
you Google 50 star Productions it comes
up with a listing like her Google page
is a picture of her garage yeah yeah
exactly like I am pretty sure my friend
this is his aunt because like it looks
exactly like his aunt and like he has an
Aunt Patty I'm pretty sure this is Patty
so wow crazy thing but she specializes
in she's like yeah I'm gonna just do
this so she was like I'm gonna go for
giant flags and it's not like she just
was like you know some cute Old Lady Who
Was knitting and somebody happened to be
like oh I'll buy one from you no this is
a business he was like she started off
by buying the flags she would buy them
for 40K and then she would rent them out
for these events and like basically had
a rental business then she's like all
right these flags I'm buying they're low
quality they have this big problem which
is that they uh like if there's a giant
gust of wind the flag turns into a huge
sale like it's like a giant player takes
the people up who are holding it exactly
it's like James and the Giant Peach
happens at the NFL game so they switched
it what she does now is they um it's
like actually like 15 different pieces
that latch together to create the flag
but when you zoom out you can't see that
it's latched and so that makes it way
easier to transport it adds a little
airflow so that the that it doesn't make
the people fly away or whatever and she
rents these out for seven thousand seven
seven thousand dollars per event and she
does about a hundred thirty to 150
events per year she does about a million
dollars in sales a year uh with her and
one dude who's her Stitch Guy and um and
that's their business and then she has
like these two competitors super flag
and this other guy that's like no no no
our flags our flags are the [__] and so
they're like competing against each
other to be the giant flag at all these
games because now every game does this
every football game does this basketball
games do this um it is a is a like a
random Niche that that she is like
number one in and what a sick gig she
probably gets to see all these stadiums
go backstage and like walks by Beyonce
when she's done singing the National
Anthem I mean this is awesome this is
yeah Beyonce said nice flag to her uh
yeah she uh so she's my like this is my
blue collar side hustle of the week
because I just think this is like such a
smart little thing and I also think that
you could
like somebody could compete with this I
got a little idea here which is
okay she fixed the airflow problem and
making it smaller so that it's not like
this giant heavy thing that you have to
like transport in and out of the stadium
but you still need 300 people standing
around it to hold it taut so that it
like because they can't put it on the
floor can't fly can't touch the ground
and um
and so yeah for example why you need 300
people is it really just for that
symbolic reason or is there I think you
want to hold it so it's like straight
it's like tight and so it looks good but
then also it can't touch the ground as I
learned dude I don't know if I told you
this in my I have two embarrassing
stories from elementary school one of
them is uh
I got assigned flag Duty on the ground
when you're just put on the ground when
I was working on the clip and then the
person was like no no no no no no no and
I was like what and they're like you
can't touch the ground and I was like oh
is this like a you know the floor is
lava like are we playing imaginary games
here and they were like we have to burn
this flag now and I was like dude I'm
already the only Brown kid in the school
and now I have to burn the flag like
Jesus this is not gonna look good for me
at lunch today
that's so funny I could see you like
getting like holding it during the
Pledge of Allegiance and then just not
knowing what to do after just put it on
there
everybody was looking at me and I had no
idea I was just fiddling with the clip
trying to like figure it out and I was
like what just what's the problem and it
made no sense to me I was like okay look
yes I did something wrong I guess but
you guys are weird about this dude I
think the symbolic stuff is a little
funny I mean there's like people have
American flags for like beach towels
like you know what I mean like if it
could like rub against your crotch we
could set it on the ground sometimes
yeah exactly exactly
I can find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
[Music]
some other things about the Super Bowl
that I think are kind of crazy let's
talk about
ads so Super Bowl ads kind of get a lot
of attention
um there's a bunch of different ways we
can go with this I have some stats
I have some hot takes but I'm curious I
want to hear your your take first on ads
you have anything interesting on ads
it's 6 million now is it six million
seven seven million for 30 seconds plus
it's the cost of actually filming it
which is typically involves like getting
Will Ferrell or something so that's like
another million easily another million
if you if you go that route yeah uh it
seems worth it though like a coinbase
did something cool it does I mean your
internet traffic spikes right away
what's interesting is the what I didn't
realize when I was researching this is
they test it a lot of times so they'll
um release multiple YouTube videos early
on and just see like what's the traction
and then go with the winning one so
that's kind of interesting but
it actually seems worth it in a lot of
cases
so um so I did some math on this last
year with the coinbase on so the
coinbase one went nuts so if you don't
remember last year coinbase did an ad
that was pretty funny there's two two
ads I think were really interesting ads
that people have done so coinbase and
AdWords just a full black screen so
there's no branding on the screen and
there was just a QR code that was
bouncing around the screen like the old
DVD like screensaver type thing where it
would like you're kind of wanting it to
land perfectly in the corner but it does
never really does and they just had that
on the screen for 30 seconds or a minute
or something like that with with music
it was just a flashing QR code and um
and they came out and said that 20
million people visited the site uh in
one minute as that was crazy uh it was
actually kind of crazy so you can
probably assume that maybe like a little
bit more than that eventually you know
came it crashed their app which was like
unfortunate for them so you know uh it
was so good that it crashed our app uh
was kind of the thing and um I did some
math on it and I think maybe it's hard
to estimate the stuff because you don't
know how many people are just gonna
check it out and be like okay I'm not
interested in signing up for crypto
right now or like I already know what
coinbase is so you gotta like discount
but basically let's assume for a second
20 million people
um
go ahead and come to your site
and you can assume some conversion rate
so I don't know what you want to see
convert three percent yeah even three
percent is probably a little high but
like one let's just say let's just say
one percent so that's 200 000 people
that sign up and then for something like
coinbase they have to like link an
account so let's say like you know
another uh you know
let's even save 20 of people link their
account afterwards now you got forty
thousand linked accounts but that's just
during that kind of one minute time span
but let's just start there their average
user is worth 45 dollars to them per
year
um and so that's 1.8 million of like
kind of like
if these people perform like an average
user so you get two million two million
back out you've probably spent uh you
know seven to six seven million total on
the ad it doesn't work out great there
but then you think it's year one there's
all this PR about coinbase and people
talk about the ad and blah blah blah
things like that maybe the ltv's higher
maybe it's a little lower because
they're less than 10 I don't know I
think it's pretty hard to break even I
emailed somebody who um who was an
investor in um hint hint water and
during the Super Bowl a few years ago
hint bought an ad last minute and they
emailed out to their investors they're
like yo by the way check it out I
remember we bought an ad
and so I asked him I said can you share
uh like like what did they say if it
worked or if it was good here's what
they said for what it's worth they said
it was great in so many ways we got 70
of the country because they bought like
not the whole nation do you want like
you know three of the top markets they
go you know the normal price would have
been about five million we got it for
one million so we got a huge discount
because we got a last minute buy
um
they say uh you know you never know uh
they go when you buy that way you don't
know when you're gonna end up we ended
up right before halftime which is a
golden spot
um direct to Consumer numbers were good
but not off the charts
um on in terms of sales traffic was off
the charts and then it's like yeah but
it builds awareness and then my
employees loved it they were like oh wow
your friends are texting you saying I
saw your guys Super Bowl ad
um you know overall you know it was
great experience and I think that's the
the thing is it's kind of a hand wavy
it's kind of a hand wavy thing the top
advertisers are always you know cars
beer snacks and then Finance stuff and
um you know those are the categories
that I think take off now did you ever
see the Reddit ad from a while back I
thought this one was awesome so what
Reddit did was they bought somehow a
five second ad
in the Super Bowl so it just flashed on
the screen and it was just an image with
text it looked like a Reddit post and it
was a Reddit post from this subreddit
which I don't know if you've ever seen
called superb owl no it's the same
spelling as Super Bowl but somebody had
created it on Reddit and it was like oh
yeah this is a Reddit for superb owls
like fantastic owls and so if you go
there it's just pictures of
Majestic owls dope owls and it gets all
this traffic during Super Bowl weekend
because it's r Super Bowl
um and so they they put up this email
Super Bowl I get it yeah and so I can
share this this image but I'll read you
what they what they wrote but it was
really smart they go wow this actually
worked if you're reading this this it
means our bet paid off these big game
spots are expensive we couldn't buy a
full one so we spent our entire Year's
marketing Budget on five seconds of air
time one thing we learned is that our
from our communities is that underdogs
can accomplish anything with they come
come together around a common idea so
who knows maybe you'll be the reason
that Finance textbooks have to add a
chapter on 10 days maybe you'll go to
superbal and teach about the and learn
about the Majesty of owls maybe it'll
pause this five second ad and take a
screenshot uh powerful things happen
when people rally around things they
really care about and there's a place
for that it's called Reddit and so
really smart that they kind of flash
something people like what was that and
then it goes viral on social media as
like oh that was a really smart thing
really cool here's what that text said
and so they saw this like traffic you
know whatever some crazy traffic Spike
but here's what's what's weird
coinbase had said uh they kind of
released this article like bragging
about it they were like our downloads
were up 300 over last week
and I was like 300 it was like 287 I was
like 287 that's it you just spent
millions of dollars on an ad push with
100 million people watching and you only
tripled your downloads from the previous
week when nothing was going on that
seems like really weak to me but
everybody all the news articles promote
that as like incredibly successful
campaign and I'm like that to me that
needs to be like 20x 30X 50 yeah last
year this was last year when like there
was a bull market and like coinbase was
already one of the top finance apps in
the country
no it jumped from ranked 168th in the
App Store to number one
and I was like how is that I don't even
understand how these numbers work so
something might be wrong in these
numbers it doesn't make a lot of sense
um I think it's not worth it what's
crazy by the way there's about 40 to 50
minutes of ads in the Super Bowl and the
game's only 60 Minutes long so the ad
load on the Super Bowl is crazy it's
like 40 to 50 percent of the entire show
is ADS so if you compare that to like I
think a TV
um ad load is about 15 so 15 in an hour
you're gonna see 15 minutes of ads
um for this you know in an hour of game
time you're gonna see you know for every
hour of game time you're seeing 40 to 50
minutes of ads which is kind of insane
um YouTube for example is three minutes
of ads for every hour of video that
you're gonna watch just to show you like
as a comparison how those things go uh
which is pretty pretty wild
um yeah a couple I don't know a couple
other things on ads real quick uh
okay so here's here's my other part that
I think is is good on that
there's a bunch of ads that are not
commercials and
um basically there's ad inventory that's
not commercials so have you ever seen uh
you know like at the end of the game
they do the Gatorade bath where they
they dump Gatorade on the winning coach
so that just happened organically that
wasn't like a paid stunt
um but Gatorade was like oh my God
jackpot and so every year that happens
now Gatorade doesn't have to pay for it
and they basically get 10 seconds of
like a native ad of Gatorade in the
winning moment like right when the team
is like you know it's the peak of the
peak they're they're about to win it's
confirmed and Gatorade gets on the
screen every single time to me that's
actually the best ad in the Super Bowl
because of how it's done it's zero cost
and they get everybody to watch that
thing right when it happens
but they don't pay now they don't pay
their Court well they're sponsors
they don't even sponsor the the game are
they sponsored just like the NFL in
general to have that can there but they
don't sponsor they don't pay anything
extra for that moment the better thing
is the you ever seen the thing where the
at the end they interview the
quarterback you just won the Super Bowl
what are you yeah I'm going to
Disneyland I'm going to Disney World do
you know the backstory of this no it's
pretty cool it's pretty cool so Michael
Eisner who is the CEO of Disney he's at
a dinner with George Lucas the creator
of Star Wars and it's Tim it's George
Lucas and it's some couple that had just
completed like the the first round the
world flight
by uh by a person like non-stop around
the world flight and so they're all at
dinner
and the food's taking a little time to
come so there's some dead time here and
and eisner's like okay well what a bunch
of great stories that that table would
have that's right
but for some reason there was a lull and
I thought so what do you do he goes
he goes well now that you've
accomplished the Pinnacle of your
aspirations what could you possibly do
next and um and they go well we're going
to Disney World and they all started
laughing and you know he's the CEO of
Disney and he's like yeah he's like
that's a great answer and his wife goes
that should be your slogan and he thinks
about that and the Super Bowl was coming
up I think a couple weeks later so they
call up the Agents of the two
quarterbacks that are playing in the
game John Elway
and they say hey we'd like to make you
an offer
which is that at the end of the game
when they say how does it feel what are
you gonna do you know like uh you know
they ask you that question we want you
to say we're going to Disney World and
um he's like we'll pay you 75 000 and
we'll give you a free trip to Disney
World if you do this he offers both both
the guys the same deal what year what
year this is 85 I think something like
that okay or maybe oh 87. okay
so Phil uh so Phil Sims ends up being
the winning quarterback he uh and he at
the time he was like telling his agent
he's like no I don't even think about
this [__] no like this seems like bad
luck to start planning my my Victory
celebration and his agent's like dude
come on like 75 grand like that was a
big deal back then he's like uh he's
like you know this is a great bonus for
you all you gotta do is say this one
line if you win uh what's it to you you
know and your whole family they'll take
you out to Disneyland Disney World no
problem and so there's this amazing clip
we can put the clip in the YouTube video
but it's a
um it's a link to this uh I'll put it in
here anyways you can see it but it's
basically the he's like running away
from the field and he turns back it like
looks like it's from a movie basically
and the reporter's like you know what
are you gonna do now and he goes I'm
going to Disney World or we're going to
Disney World and he says that became the
thing and so then every year Disney
would approach the whoever they think
might get the interview at the end and
they offer them the deal and they say
hey whether you win or lose you're gonna
get this money uh but if you are the
winner we want you to say this and um so
they pay the loser and they pay the
winner and the winners got to say it and
now it's become such a thing that
Patrick Mahomes one of the quarterbacks
who's in this year's Super Bowl just
says it probably he tweeted out like
years ago he goes man it must be the
best feeling to be that quarterback who
gets to say we're going to Disney World
I can't wait
and it's like wow that's the problem
great marketing right and and it's also
is a it's awesome and B it's
painful everything that I think is this
is it's like learning that Santa
nothing's real bro yeah it's all fake uh
that's wild it's all fake it's all
nonsense but that's awesome that's crazy
what what a smart move that's a really
wise move and so I have um I have
prepared for you
you know we have our drunk ideas uh
podcast which uh which we should do
another edition of drunk ideas where I
pitch you you know half-baked bat you
know kind of bad ideas that you'd only
think are good when you're drunk
I have a new edition called drunk CMO so
now I'm the drunk CMO and these are my
drunk idea my drunk marketing ideas for
you I want you to just rate them uh uh
you know great you know okay or terrible
um
okay so here's my first idea uh I'm the
drunk CMO I come into you I say hey boss
I got an idea for the Super Bowl
you say great or bad I say let me hear
your idea yeah go ahead whatever I'm
here right here all right so here's the
deal somebody's gonna score a touchdown
and all eyes are on them it's a
celebration moment
if you know players in the NFL if they
celebrate too much if they dance they
get fined like twenty thousand dollars
fifty thousand dollars here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna go to all the wide
receivers and we're gonna tell them look
not only will we pay your fine
we're gonna triple whatever you get
fined you get to keep that
but here's what you got to do you're
you're gonna have a branded celebration
so uh I don't know what our brand is
let's say we're a beer brand you're
gonna run to this we have a fat guy in
the in the seats right next to the end
zone you're gonna crack open a cold one
and you're gonna chug that baby
pour that on your face you're just gonna
do a chewy right there on the spot it's
gonna go crazy viral you're gonna be
seen as Mr fun as like you know this
epic badass and we're gonna get our
product placed in that great idea you
know depending on whatever our product
is you know if we're dude wipes you're
gonna go take this and you're gonna take
this wipe and you're gonna wipe you know
right there right here whatever our
product is you're slim jim you're gonna
snap open a slim jim
um that's the idea we're going to Brand
the Super Bowl celebration what do you
say how about that a great idea I mean
so I don't pay attention to sports the
things that I remember is the Rams doing
the what was their thing called the
where they would like uh you know like
when they would celebrate the dirty bird
I thought it was the St Louis Rams where
I'm from they would like do like the the
Huddle where they would do their stupid
thing and then also Randy Moss pulling
out uh Sharpie and signing the ball and
throwing it out these are like iconic
moments I'm on board with this this is
all so whatever the brand is I'm going
to those guys I'm saying hey we haven't
we bought seats in the end zone you just
gotta go grab the thing from this guy
and do the do the celebration we got you
and okay here's the next one
hey boss uh I know Taco sales are down
for us this year uh but I got a big idea
I could save us I could save us here in
the fourth in in the quarter uh our
earnings are coming up earnings Hall's
coming up Taco sales are down
stay with me boss
tacos for tails
during the coin flip if it's Tails
everybody gets a free Taco anybody can
go there and just say tails at the
window and get one free Taco everybody's
now rooting it's not 50 50 baby we're
gonna have the power of America on our
side rooting for Tails we're gonna take
that moment of the game and we're going
to turn it into a marketing moment
dude I would say Drake more often these
are great when I was a kid when I was a
kid they had Big Mac land you know the
Cardinals we had Mark McGuire and if
when he was on his home run thing if he
hit his home run in a certain section
you gotta be everyone in the stadium got
a Big Mac and so his Big Mac land was
like the section it was awesome I loved
it and whenever he hit a home run in
that section they would have the
spotlights over McDonald's so everyone
knew we got to run to Big Macland uh
yeah in also awesome all right
Taco for Tails tacos for Tails you're in
dude if anything is alliterative like
that I'm automatically in I love two T's
okay so here's another one um hey boss
uh you know that car companies like us
uh we spend the most on Super Bowl ads
right but we don't get the budget who's
got the budget for that kind of thing
where are we gonna spend 20 million
dollars this year on Super Bowl ads for
our car
um what are we Kia yeah yeah or Kia and
so you know what are we gonna do here
's what we're gonna do
I don't know if you noticed boss but
this is this new trend of when players
arrive for the game the cameras kind of
show them walking out with their outfit
as they're walking in with their Beats
by Dre headphones or their briefcase and
they're like coming in for the job and
it's like in the pre-game there's no
there's just they're trying to fill time
so that oh Patrick Mahomes is here look
at him he's entering the building
wait a minute this whole entering the
building thing say it with me boss
marketing moment why don't we put them
in baller cars that are just tricked out
beyond belief and they're gonna we're
gonna film the actual arrival at the
stadium and I think actually it's Rolls
Royce who should do this but they should
the Rolls-Royce needs to transport
everybody in badass rolls royces to the
stadium and the quarterbacks get the
best whatever the Phantom triple
whatever this is for a luxury brand
Lamborghini whoever it is you gotta you
gotta get the players to show up in
style because TV will pick that up of
them showing up there needs to be a
freaking fog machine and it just needs
to look crazy and so we're branding that
moment and actually I got my buddies
here from Louis Vuitton they're also
gonna just put just drip everybody's
outfit out because this now this
entrance is a red carpet entrance and
we're gonna we're gonna own that red
carpet entrance from from the moment
they arrive at the stadium what do you
think look the thing about classy is you
can't try too hard and now you're trying
too hard that's not
unless we're talking about like what do
I want a souped up Acura I mean like
what are we gonna do here like like I've
learned enough like I've seen enough
Hummer limos in my life I don't think
you can make those things cool I'm out
all right boss uh listen
I don't know I don't know if it's uh if
it's me I don't know if it's my
allergies I don't know if I've been
drinking too much but I'm just I'm
stumped on ideas here
I just I just can't I'm a writer's block
I just got no ideas so here's what we're
gonna do
we're gonna go name Mr Beast our
temporary CMO for the weekend and we're
going to give Mr Beast our entire budget
and we're going to say Mr Beast
you take our 10 million dollar Super
Bowl budget and you do a video
on your own you come up with your own
Super Bowl marketing campaign that is
different than whatever's going to be in
the Super Bowl this guy gets 100 million
views per video and people love them and
he's not just it's gonna stand out we're
gonna instead what we're gonna do
actually here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna buy airtime the kind of like
the the 15 second or 30 second ad slot
and it's just going to tell people to go
watch Mr BEAST's video
um or it's gonna be Mr Beast on the
screen and he's going to be clicking
upload and then you have to go to his
channel to see what the actual video is
what do you think boss
I'm out I'm out dog too many steps
that's too you're getting too creative
for me you're trying to win an award not
make me money
I do like the awards as a CMO I kind of
build my whole reputation not on dudes
but on industry Awards peers if I hear a
marketing person brag about an award I'm
automatically out I cannot stand those
types of people
really funny it's an award idea with the
coinbase thing so they were getting a
bunch of props for their ad do you
remember what happened last year when
the coinbase CEO came out and was just
like people have been asking so here's
the backstory around the ad yeah you
made up this whole story he said this
whole story where he was like you know
we just wanted something cool everything
seemed so cliche we got all these
pictures from ad agencies about
celebrities I never he's like side note
I don't even understand why people would
buy a product because of celebrities
test I've never made sense to me and he
just lost programmers going to say
dunked on he was just someone was just
tossing up the basketball and this woman
comes in and just dunks him right in his
face and so he's like you know the team
came up with this idea it required no
budget it delivered this epic return
because it was so different no agency
would have ever thought about this and
this woman comes in and she goes except
an agency did think about this my agency
we presented it to you on 813 slide 19
is our is our idea for this
and then people and then all the Ad
Agency people were like get him they
were like we never get respect and so
they all were like this is about client
agency respect and they made it like a
bigger deal like they try to create like
a BLM movement but for agencies and it
just didn't catch on but like people
tried and then he had to come back and
be like but the the weak move so so all
of it was fine I actually have no
problem with any of it up till this
point uh whatever he said I have no
problem with what she did cool great
great move on her part too the small boy
stuff was at the end he comes back and
he goes
oh I I'm so sorry the team was working
together so well with the agency I just
thought it was all one team the the
collaboration was so good that it just
seemed like it was all our own internal
team they were so integrated
bro that's like me said that's like I
walked in on my sister once when she my
mom was like go tell your sister to
study and I walked in and she was
sleeping and I go mom she's sleeping she
goes I'm not sleeping I'm reviewing in
my head and I go oh she's studying in
her head it's like the world's worst
excuse was I the team was so so cohesive
I just thought it was us
yeah that's why you didn't give credit
dude I like that guy Brian I'm a big fan
of his he got dunked on there he that
was a that was a that was a loss on that
on his part that's the only like big
loss I've seen him have a few else but
we all take our L's right we got yeah we
got a pocket full of else
um all right here's here's another one
um
uh let's see okay so now the ad concept
itself if you had to create an ad that
you think would work what would you do
to make a good ad for the Super Bowl oh
man I'd probably just make a bunch of
them and just run them on Tick Tock or
YouTube and see which one is doing okay
and just do whatever that one is yes
that's like good testing but like um
what do you think would actually make a
good ad
board make an ad that actually gets
people to convert
Matt Damon
three strategies yeah
epic story
Matt Damon or what I think is I think
what somebody should do
this is not allowed because they reject
these ideas but I think you got to
create some drama so I think you want to
have
a sort of like a will it or won't it
moment and so like you know I want to
see a mouse in a tank with a snake
and there's just tension
it's like what's gonna happen here
and there's like one safe place the
mouse can go and it's like this is AAA
ad and it's brought to you by AAA it's
like it's the mouse gonna what's gonna
happen to this map there's a man in a
box and he needs your help that's the
premise let's go let's riff off of that
yeah I think you gotta have some drama
and I think maybe run it at the
beginning of this show and then you have
like the YouTube channel where it's live
streaming oh my God go to go to YouTube
and see what see will it or won't it
what's gonna happen
um
will it or won't it concept this is
awesome it's a great concept I remember
going to a bar once this isn't it always
will by the way a great marketing thing
that happened once was uh I went to this
bar
and the bar owner was like dude we need
to come up with a way for people to like
buy more drinks or something like and I
was like oh you could hire dancers you
could do this you could do that like you
know make this club like he's like I
don't get the money for all that and so
we went back like a month later and he
had done the most genius thing is in
Australia have you ever heard of a crab
race
no no
does the winner not get eaten or
something well no it's kind of like it's
just the most random dumb thing but
everybody got so excited it took a giant
Bowl he filled it with these like mini
hermit crabs and each hermit crab he
just took a Sharpie and he wrote a
number one through 50 on it and then
basically he's like it's time for The
Crab race go buy a drink and pick a
number and so everybody gets to buy a
drink pick a number and if that's your
crab wins the race so they basically put
the crabs in a bowl they put it in the
middle of the circle they remove the
bowl and there's an outer ring and who
whichever crab gets to the outer ring
first wins and that is the hero crab he
gets to like come back next week and
like defend his his championship
um and anybody who bet on that crab gets
like whatever's either some money or
like free they're like free shots for
like you know you and all your friends
or whatever it is and so it just created
this hype people started dying every
week for this thing I don't I don't
think he invented it I think other bars
do this but he like he brought that
concept into his bar the first time I
had ever seen it I've never seen an
American Bar do this and I cannot tell
you how much excitement this this one
simple thing
we need that for this podcast
every episode yeah that's that's really
awesome that's a great idea people in
the comments on YouTube should bet a
number pick a number
and we just and then at the end of the
episode are they in like every other
episode or whatever we like do the
reveal and we uh we show who won
uh we should do that we should do that
for this podcast we should do something
like that for the Pod call your crab guy
and I'm not a guy yeah
forgot one of my favorite ones dude you
might you'll appreciate this as a dog
guy have you seen the Puppy Bowl
I love the Puppy Bowl genius genius idea
that the who's the Animal Planet did I
think basically what happened was they
were like
the like you know the head of
programming it's like hey what are we
gonna run this Sunday to that that will
get ratings and they're like uh against
the Super Bowl great yeah let me uh like
thanks for the impossible task what can
I come up with that's gonna run on
Sunday against the Super Bowl and still
get viewers and that's when they created
The Puppy Bowl which is kind of actually
the same idea as the Crab race the
basically it's a bunch of puppies with
toys and there's a ref and basically if
any puppy randomly Walks Into The End
Zone with a toy the ref is like
touchdown this guy scored
you missed one low hanging fruit that I
thought was pretty obvious super blunt
Sunday what are we gonna do with that
I know I don't know yet but it's super
blonde Sunday it all starts with the
phrase I like super blunt Sunday surely
we will work backwards from the name
kind of guy I know yeah
um anyway
good pot people are gonna have some
facts yeah you get to be a know-it-all
this Sunday and just remember everybody
loves a know it all
to roll in
[Music]